(driving orchestral music)
- [Narrator] At New York's
American Museum of Natural History,
we are past the Roosevelt Atrium,
through the Frick Building,
and tucked away behind drawers of bones,
Doctor Jack Tseng is hard at work.
He's a dog guy.
- Well, I have worked on dog evolution
and dog fossil for about 10 years.
- [Narrator] Jack's the man
when it comes to dog evolution,
and he says dogs might have
a shot at outliving us all.
(moves into light orchestral music)
- [Narrator] Humans have been evolving
for roughly 3 million years,
but dogs have been around way longer.
- And that history goes all
the way back 40 million years.
- [Narrator] It hasn't been easy.
(chirping)
They've dealt with warming,
cooling, the Ice Age.
To determine how dogs are going to fare
as the world changes,
(digital whizzing)
you have to start in the past.
Because dogs are evolutionary marvels.
The first dogs weren't really
dogs as we know them today.
They were tree-dwellers and really small.
They changed to survive.
(whooshing)
They're legs lengthened
(digital beeping)
so they could run
(whooshing)
longer distances and they grew a lot.
During the Ice Age,
(whooshing)
the big wolves weighed around 140 pounds.
But it's their teeth
that are really the key to their survival.
- Their teeth were getting stronger
to deal with a larger bones
and the grit
(whooshing)
that they make
(clicking)
in your mouth when you're hunting.
- [Narrator] What he's saying
is that it's biological
that dogs are eating machines.
Think of their teeth
(whooshing)
as a basic blueprint
(digital beeping)
that goes back 40 million years
and can be adapted to any kind
of environmental change.
(digital beep)
The teeth in the back crush bone,
those teeth
(digital beep)
in the middle are for cutting,
and the front teeth
(digital beep)
are for puncturing.
What's more,
(whooshing)
dogs teeth have reinforced surfaces.
That means their teeth
(crunching)
will stay in tact whether they're eating
large bones
(whooshing)
or chewing up carcasses.
It also means dogs don't really need us.
(light dreamy music)
They'll be able to survive
even if we're no longer around
to feed them, because they can eat
pretty much anything that comes their way.
- If we do go and they're
alive, I'm sure they will adapt
to whatever environment
that comes their way.